Game four of the 2017 Grantchester in  Leuven Belgium it was on to blitz as the  world's best players rolled up their  sleeve to play pressure packed chest at  a lightning pace a surging in each  period changed the poster tournament by  defeating both world champion Magnus  Crossan and tournament leader Wesley so  in successive games in this one game  anything can happen so it happened that  set up a crucial last round match of  that magnitude dominated to move into a  tie with Seoul with also play four on  the final day there is a big job yet to  be done tomorrow I don't have the  advantage of coming from behind it finds  a promise champion with nine rounds of  chess played at top speed the last day  of heart racing action starts right now